[Music]
broadcom software is one of the world's
leading enterprise software companies
modernizing optimizing and securing some
of the world's largest
most complex hybrid environments
and have built a wide portfolio of
industry leading enterprise
infrastructure and security software
have the privilege of
leading some of the best engineers and
architects
as part of the sas platform engineering
within broadcom software we believe that
devops is a culture
that fosters innovation breaks barriers
between development and operations teams
improves efficiencies and productivity
the the primary business drivers uh for
this effort was again the diverse
portfolio of products that we had within
sas
broadcom grows
organically and inorganically through
acquisitions
we acquired products
that are industry leaders that have
grown over a period of time that have
built on different technology stacks
built with different methodologies
and run on on-prem private and public
clouds and operate differently we had to
build a common standard platform where
these products could run where we could
leverage the efficiencies across these
products
this common platform would include like
infrastructure as a service and the
kubernetes orchestration layer
standard devops and security practices
adopted across
and leveraging a common set of devsecops
tools like the ci cd pipeline we
understood that one size doesn't fit all
but it was kind of surprising as we
started
migrating many of these products into
container based architectures there were
a lot of common strands across this uh
wide heterogeneous work set of workloads
that we had in the security panoply of
software that we had we were able to
extract a lot of common strands across
say for example observability like
monitoring metrics alerting logging and
some of the security tooling that we
could do that could uh that could
monitor this environment we were
surprised to see the amount of
commonality which was there that we
could leverage and make this whole
process more efficient google has been a
strong reliable partner and a trusted
partner
for us in this journey and it's fair to
say that without them
we would not have been able to
accomplish what we did over the last few
years
and this this is the large program a lot
of moving parts we didn't have
challenges but google was always there
uh available to us responsive and
innovative in their solutions really
this transformation was not possible
without google and
we are definitely thankful to google for
for that